[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso oriente El magazine
quincenal de France 24 en el que les
acercamos las historias de medio oriente
América Latina Esto es lo que veremos
hoy la discordia viviendo los picos de
violencia más graves en años unas
tensiones agravadas por los planes
expansionistas del gobierno
ultraderechista de Israel
un mes después de los terremotos que
devastaron el sur de Turquía y el norte
de Siria los refugiados sirios viven un
recrudecimiento del racismo mientras
intentan sobrevivir tras la catástrofe
natural
y el Líbano la población sigue
padeciendo en medio de una crisis
económica y social sin precedentes más
del 80% de la población vive bajo el
umbral de pobreza y muchos libaneses no
alcanzan a cubrir la canasta básica
iniciamos en la cisjordania ocupada con
el repunte de violencia los territorios
palestinos ocupados por parte de colonos
israelís el departamento de estado
estadounidense publicó un informe en el
que señala que Israel a menudo no evitó
los ataques de los colonos contra
palestinos durante el 2021 algo que se
está acentuando con la coalición
ultraderechista de gobierno previamente
hablamos con cazamoadi él es periodista
palestino basado en ramala y le
preguntamos sobre Por qué está
incrementando estos ataques de colonos y
las fuerzas de seguridad israelíes en
localidades estratégicas sí está ola de
violencia israelí contra ciudades
palestinas
tiene llevándose a cabo desde hace más
de un año y se ha concentrado en una
blusa y recientemente Jericó también la
razón es simplemente que en estas zonas
particularmente
ha venido desarrollando un fenómeno
digamos la extensión de un fenómeno que
siempre ha existido que es el de el
activismo de los palestinos contra de la
ocupación israelí digamos que siempre es
de que la ocupación comenzó hace 50 años
los palestinos siempre enfrentan a las
fuerzas israelíes cuando impulsan en las
ciudades con piedras en estos lugares de
hace casi un año jóvenes palestinos
mayoritariamente no organizados en
ninguna facción mayoritariamente sus 20
y 30 sin experiencia política
o militante han venido armándose y esto
ha venido creando un fenómeno que
preocupa a Israel porque desafía su
control de cisjordania y las incursiones
se realizan vuelto más violentas porque
van dirigidas a toda la población como
una manera de
de reprimir la población para quitarle
el apoyo a estos grupos que se han
venido Armando Como la forma de
controlar y someternos
también nos explicó cuál puede ser la
deriva regional con el incremento de los
asentamientos ilegales por parte de los
colonos israelíes
la expansión de las colonias nunca se
detuvo un solo día y lo que es dijo hace
pocos días desafiando
a la administración norteamericana que
la expansión de las colonias no se
tendrá un solo día Es solamente una a un
anuncio Público de lo que siempre ha
sido una política
israelí con constante lo que sucede Lo
que sí es variante Es que con Colón nos
extremistas dentro del gobierno los
colonos se sienten más apoderados y se
sienten con más impunidad y con las
manos sueltas también vemos otros
fenómenos por ejemplo que ahora Israel
comienza la formación de una nueva
Fuerza Armada que van a llamar la
guardia nacional que básicamente se va a
formar como los reportes parecen indicar
de colonos eso es muy peligroso porque
la población Palestina está
completamente indefensa los pocos son
[Música]
y la población Palestina se encuentra en
una situación muy vulnerable en esa
situación Por eso pero el factor
importante aquí es que durante tantos
años no ha habido ninguna presión
consistente verdadera sobre el gobierno
de Israel por parte de la comunidad
internacional por eso Israel hoy se
siente simplemente libre de hacer lo que
quiera más aún con extremistas dentro
del gobierno cambiamos de tema a un mes
de los desvastadores terremotos en el
sur de Turquía y el norte de Siria con
casi 50.000 muertos miles de refugiados
sirios siguen en el Limbo y en el
desamparo una crisis humanitaria que ha
agudizado el racismo y la hostilidad
mientras del lado sirio esperan la ayuda
humanitaria que sigue llegando a
cuentagotas para hablar de esto tenemos
desde España a octamo a Matt él es
periodista sirio y fundador del medio
vainana Gracias por acompañarnos quería
preguntarte qué está ocurriendo
con los refugiados sirios en Turquía y
qué está haciendo el gobierno Turco para
protegerlos
bueno el primero en la parte del sur de
Turquía es que es el centro del
terremoto
debía antes del terremoto un millón y
700.000 refugiados sirios en esta zona y
después del terremoto hay mucha gente se
quedaron sin sin hogar sin casas y hay
mucha gente se está viviendo en tiendas
de campaña ahora mismo Está refugiando a
la calle sobre todo porque hay réplicas
de vez en cuando y la gente tiene mucho
miedo el nombre de refugiados sirios que
volvieron al noroeste de Siria desde
Turquía cerca de 44.000 personas algunos
se han vuelto para ver y visitar a sus
familiares y otros volvieron al noroeste
porque no lo quedaron nada en Turquía
después del terremoto y el gobierno
Turco ha facilitado estas vueltas porque
bordó cosas uno
para animar que los refugiados se queda
en su país y dos para que visitan a sus
familiares y si quieren volver a Turquía
ya después que no hay problema varias
personas también han denunciado racismo
contra esta población refugiada en
Turquía A qué se debe y Cómo se
manifiesta
Ahí casi cuatro millones de refugiados
sirios viven en Turquía Entonces el
racismo existía siempre contra los
sirios y además
ahora se está aumentando Y es más
complicado los refugiados diarios en
Turquía por el terremoto y
el Yo creo que es al revés porque el
gobierno de ardoán que siempre habla de
que quiere mejorar la situación de las
refugiados y tal Aunque amenaza a Europa
siempre por tema de los refugiados
sirios para recibir dinero pero la
obsesión de ordogan como amenaza cuando
llega al poder va a echar a los
refugiados sirios
Mostrar el contrario no Entonces es Yo
creo que es un es un es un papel
es un juego entre entre los manos del
gobierno que sea de arduano de la
oposición el tema de los refugiados en
Turquía y al respecto
hemos acabamos de publicar un artículo
de una compañera nuestra que está en
Turquía
estás denunciando el racismo porque ha
perdido su hogar y por el terremoto
además de perder 50 personas de sus
familiares
no está encontrando una casa y porque
los
turcos no quieren alquilarla un piso por
ser refugiada Siria ustedes cofundador
de un medio creado por refugiados
inmigrantes sirios en España que es
banana bueno bailana es el primer medio
de comunicación
en español en árabe creado por
periodistas refugiados sirios hemos
creado este medio en abril de 2021 para
informar sobre la situación de los
migrantes y los refugiados en España en
particular porque vivimos aquí también
en otros países europeos y la ruta
migratorias de Grecia de otras rutas
también y porque no creemos que no hay
suficiente cobertura profunda de las de
los migrantes en Europa no por parte de
los medios también porque nosotros bueno
desde la perspectiva de un periodista
refugiado que cubrió la guerra de Siria
y ha bebido un proceso
migratorio pues tenemos una perspectiva
de informar sobre la situación de los
refugiados sin prejuicios y informar
sobre la realidad y también para romper
el estereotipo que tienen
medio de comunicación o también la gente
aquí sobre los migrantes en general
porque es tan importante este tipo de
medios independientes y creados por la
misma población Siria para el
cubrimiento de crisis humanitarias como
la del terremoto
estamos en formando desde el primer
momento del terremoto Aunque en Nuestro
objetivo principal no es Siria Aunque
somos sirios pero este caso fue
excepcional Y
si nosotros no vamos a cubrir como somos
sirios y tenemos un medio de
comunicación No creo que un otro medio
por ejemplo no tiene corresponsales en
Siria etc que nos va a cubrir mejor
entonces hemos puesto alerta máxima
desde el primer momento del terremoto y
lo estamos cubriendo con muy pocos
recursos porque nosotros no tenemos un
fuente de ingreso estable en la revista
y acabamos también de lanzar un proyecto
que se llama voces de Siria es como el
artículo que acabo de contar para que
los periodistas sirios que están en el
terreno en Siria o en el sur de Turquía
del centro del terremoto que en forman
es una forma para apoyarles Porque viven
al margen no
y también
para que
para para cubrir las consecuencias del
terremoto y no dejarla como cualquier
otro
otra cosa que ocurre en el mundo lo
toman como
como una moda no una semana o dos
semanas y ya está porque eso es un
terremoto ha dejado miles de muertos y
tienes consecuencias a lo largo del
tiempo y necesita cobertura continua
Gracias ok va por estar en France 24 y
Recuerden que pueden encontrar más
información sobre este medio en
vainana.es nosotros terminamos en Líbano
la crisis económica y la inflación
récord hacen que muchos libaneses ya no
puedan pagar por la atención médica o
sus medicamentos la moneda local perdió
más del 98% de su valor desde el inicio
del colapso económico en 2019
hambruna robos escasez de alimentos y
agua potable es el paisaje diario en el
país nuestra corresponsal en beirut etel
bonet nos cuenta más sobre esta
situación desde un popular centro
comercial ahora fantasma
nos encontramos en el corazón comercial
de la ciudad de beirut en este moderno
centro comercial que emula los antiguos
zocos árabes lleno de joyerías y de
tiendas caras de marcas internacionales
pero ahora la mayoría de los
establecimientos están vacíos y cerrados
porque no hay clientes la libra libanesa
sigue cayendo en vacío y probablemente
en las próximas semanas podría alcanzar
los tres dígitos al cambio del dólar es
decir
150.000 libras libanesas por un dólar
cuando hace apenas tres años eran 1500
libras por un dólar como consecuencia
los empleados públicos están ganando
menos de 50 dólares al mes y aquellos
que tienen su dinero en las cuentas
bancarias tampoco pueden sacarlo por el
corralito impuesto por los bancos para
mitigar la crisis financiera el Líbano
navega como un barco a la deriva y los
primeros en abandonar el banco son las
autoridades no hay presidente ni
gobierno lo que hace crecer la
inestabilidad económica pero su señorías
no tienen la suficiente voluntad de
zanjar sus diferencias para poder elegir
a un nuevo jefe de estado
mientras
el corazón de beirut se ha pagado porque
la electricidad solamente llega dos
horas diarias y es que con las arcas
vacías el estado no puede adquirir
combustible Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta edición de Expreso
de oriente Los invito a seguir todas las
ediciones en nuestra página web France
24.com
[Música]